Ja? Okay, gut.
Ja.
Guten Abend. Ich bin Nuran Abdi.
Ich bin die Diensthabende Ersten in dieser Notaufnahme.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin sicher.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich ganz schnell
ein paar allgemeine Fragen für Ihre Personen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin sicher.
Ja. Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Frank Pfeiffer.
Frank Pfeiffer.
Konzense bitte Ihren Nachnamen gestabilen.
Nachnamen.
PS.
Also Vorname ist Frank, F-R-A-N-K.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Pfeiffer, P-F-E-I-S-E-R.
Dokmit Dok-L-R.
Genau.
Okay.
Herr Pfeiffer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 35.
35.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 14.09.87.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegeln Sie?
Oh, ich bin 1 Meter und 84 und wiege zur Zeit so 92 Kilo.
92.
92 Jahre.
Ja.
Herr Pfeiffer, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich bin verheiratet.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ja, ich bin Kaufmann.
Ich habe das Geschäft von meinen Eltern übernommen.
Wir haben ein Modegeschäft und da mache ich jetzt alles.
Was bilden Sie?
Für uns, was bilden Sie im Moment?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe so höchte Geschmerzen in meinem rechten Bein.
Und zwar im Unterschenkel.
Und diese Schmerzen, die strahlen so bis in die Kielkehle rein.
und das ist alles auch ein bisschen angeschwollen und die Haut ist etwas gerötet und es fühlt sich
ganz merkwürdig an, also so, dass, als ob das so aufgeblasen wäre, so ein bisschen Spannung
da drauf ist in der, in dem Unterschenkel. Und Sie haben, Sie haben im rechten Unterschenkel
eine pfiffige Schmerz. Ja, ja, ja, wobei die Schmerzen sind gar nicht so so stark, aber so
diese Spannungsgefühl, das fühlt sich so unangenehm an. Ja, Herr Vöker, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat, das hat angefangen vor zwei Tagen, erst war das nur ein bisschen und jetzt ist es eigentlich
immer mehr geworden. Ja, gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser für diese Schmerzen? Könnte es sein, dass Sie sich
verlässt haben? Nein, nein, ich habe mich nicht gestoßen oder irgendwie sowas, nein, nein. Ich bin
auf der Rückreise gewesen aus dem Urlaub und ich fühle mich auch so ein bisschen erkältet,
die Klimaanlage war im Auto an, es war ja so sonnig und dann hatten wir eine lange Rückfahrt,
hatten auch ein bisschen Staus und dann fing das nach zwei Tagen mit einmal, hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass ich da diese Schmerzen habe und erkältet bin ich jetzt eben auf, ich muss auch ständig Nase
putzen und habe so ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen. Ja, ich verstehe, gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen
liegen, dass sie sich da. Ja, also besser ist es eigentlich, wenn ich die Beine ein bisschen hoch lege,
aber ich muss ja den ganzen Tag im Geschäft stehen und arbeiten, das kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben
und das ist aber irgendwie nicht so gut. Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen
wieder weg. Nein, die sind ständig eigentlich. Haben Sie etwas probiert, um die Schmerzen zu
linden, außer hoch legen? Ja, ich habe meine Schmerzverplette genommen, aber das hat irgendwie
nichts geändert. Welches Medikament haben Sie eingenommen? Ja, ich habe Überprofäen genommen.
Aber das hat Ihnen nicht geholt? Nein, das hat vielleicht so ein bisschen diese
Erkältungssymptome weggenommen, aber das Bein hat genauso weh getan. Okay, haben Sie früher schon
einmal diese Schmerzen gehabt? So genau, so noch nie, nein. Und waren Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen beim
anderen? Nein, nein, nein, ich bin jetzt direkt zu Ihnen gekommen, weil das mir doch ein bisschen
unheimlich war. Ja. Und fühlt es sich warm an, fühlt es warm an Ihr Bein? Ob mein Bein fühlt sich, doch ja,
das fühlt sich warm an, das richtig. Okay, und haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelbrot nach Schweiz?
Also ich habe das tatsächlich jetzt gemerkt, aber ich habe das auf diese Erkältung zurückgeschoben.
Also ich fühle mich schwitzig in der Nacht, ja. Ja, erkältig. Ist Ihnen übel jetzt? Ja, so richtig übel,
nicht, aber ich habe eigentlich seit zwei Tagen nicht so richtig viel Appetit zum Essen,
aber das liegt vielleicht auch an dieser Schnupfengeschichte. Okay. Herr Pfeiffer,
ich habe vergessen, Frage, wie ich sich Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz Kalifornie gesehen, wenn
ein sehr leichter Schmerz ist, wenn ein unerwäglicher Schmerz ist. Ach, wundertrücklich ist das hier nicht,
aber unangenehm ist es, fühlt vielleicht so in der Mitte sagen bei fünf oder so. 56.
Okay, und wie können Sie diese Schmerz beschreiben? Sind die Stichen drücken? Ja,
so drückend auf alle Fälle, dieses Spannungsgefühl ist eigentlich so unangenehm und ein bisschen,
ein bisschen brennend vielleicht. Und gibt es Ihnen welche, wo Erkrankungen sind? Nein,
nein. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Schmucklwang? Nein. Und haben Sie Luftnot?
Luftnot? Nein, nein. Also jetzt ein bisschen durch diesen Schnupfen halt. Und das habe ich ziemlich
häufig, also so ein bisschen chronisch so Nebenhöhenentzündungen. Und da habe ich das
schnell mal, dass ich, dass ich halt, also nicht gut Luft kriege durch die Nase. So. Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen von denen ich das so finde? Ja, so bekannt ist,
dass ich so eine Glutenunverträglichkeit habe. Das haben wir vor drei Jahren rausgefunden.
Dann habe ich eine Schildrüssenerkrankung, Hashimoto und eben diese, diese Nebenhöhengeschichte.
Und weil ich eben im Beruf so viel stehe. Die Hashimoto-Trouilletestee, seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, das hat man vor fünf Jahren testgestellt. Vor fünf Jahren. Gibt es noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Probleme so mit Krampfalarm dadurch, dass ich den ganzen
Tag halt viel stehe bei der Arbeit. Und wurde sie schon einmal operiert? Nein, operiert.
Wurde ich noch nie. Nein, wenn ich so zurück überlege, nein, nein, ich habe noch nie eine
Operation gehabt. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein? Ja, ich nehme natürlich Ultirox ein wegen
der Schildrüssen. Ja, in welche Dosierung nehmen Sie? Das ist Ultirox ein Hundert, dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Und dann, wie gesagt, Ibuprofen oder auch mal Aspirin, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe.
Bei Bedarf. Bei Bedarf, genau. Und genauso, wenn ich sehr große Probleme habe mit den
Nebenhöhlen, dann nehme ich halt Gelomirtulkapseln. Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen? Ja, das sind so
Gelomirtulkapseln, die sind gegen Nebenhöhlenverschleimung. Die lösen da so ein bisschen die Entzündung.
Wer gehen Sie alle, wie ich auch, irgendwelche Medikamente, Lebensmittel? Ja, wie gesagt Gluten,
also normale Milchgeschichten darf ich halt nicht essen, da muss ich aufpassen.
Und da habe ich halt Bauchschmerzen und krieg Durchfall. Und ich habe eine Allergie auf
Novalgien, das darf ich nicht nehmen. Novalgien Allergie. Wie betreffend ist das? Ja, da kriege ich,
also auf der einen Seite kriege ich einen Ausschlag, also dass ich so rote Pickelchen kriege. Und
ich habe auch dann Probleme mit der Luft. Dann kriege ich so ein bisschen Atemnot.
Sind Sie gegen Corona, wenn Sie um Kinderkrankheit geimpft? Ja, also eigentlich habe ich alle Impfungen,
die man so haben muss. Und gegen Corona bin ich auch dreimal geimpft. Ja, Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben eine lange Reise gemacht. Genau, ja. Ja, wie weit es war. Ja, wir waren sieben Stunden
unterwegs im Auto. Herr Pfeffer, rauchen Sie? Oh, nicht mehr, seit fünf Jahren bin ich nicht raucher.
Seit fünf Jahren, Sie rauchen nicht. Früher, wie viel ist geradezuhause? Ja, ich habe nie so
furchtbar viel geraucht. Ich habe so von 20 bis 30, da habe ich immer mal so ein halbes Päckchen
am Tag geraucht, aber auch nicht so viel. Trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja, eigentlich trinke ich abends gerne
Glas Wein. Ein Glas Wein jeden Abend? Ja, ziemlich regelmäßig, fast jeden Abend. Ja, auch meine
erstes scheint sich, ist das zu viel. Aber es ist ein guter Wein oder, also mir bekommt das gut.
Das ist eine Routinefrage. Nehmen Sie Drogen, aber hat es nun sicherer Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Ja, in meiner Jugend habe ich mal für eine Weile ein bisschen haschisch geraucht, aber das war nur
eine ganz kurze Episode. Herr Pfeffer, gibt es irgendwelche Erkrankungen in Ihrer näheren Familie? Ich meine,
Eltern, Geschwister, Kinder. Mein Vater, der ist jetzt gar nicht so lange Zeit operiert worden,
der hat Darmkrebs und hat jetzt einen künstlichen Ausgang bekommen, aber der scheint die Operation
ganz gut überstanden zu haben. Wir hoffen alle, dass es ihm jetzt weiter gut geht. Ihre Mutter? Meine
Mutter ist eigentlich relativ gesund, sie hat ein bisschen Kniegelengsprobleme, aber sonst ist
sie fit. Haben Sie Geschwister? Nein, Geschwister habe ich gar nicht. Haben Sie Kinder? Ein Sohn habe ich. Ist der gesund? Der ist gesund, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau? Damit wir der ganzen Familie leben, wenn wir natürlich zusammen, ja, ja, sicher.
Und treiben Sie Sport? Da habe ich nicht so viel Gelegenheit dazu, wissen Sie, mit dem Geschäft
hat man ja doch viel zu tun. Wenn ich mal Zeit habe, fahre ich mal ein bisschen Fahrrad, aber
eigentlich kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich regelmäßig vortreibe. Herr Piper, ich habe
alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzuwiesen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Na ja, ich möchte jetzt natürlich ganz gerne wissen, was man gegen diese Schmerz tun kann,
wo das herkommt. Aber und vor allem möchte ich auch wissen, wann ich wieder los kann. Wissen Sie,
ich muss hier morgen wieder im Lagen stehen, ne? Ja, Herr Piper, ich verstehe, dass Sie schnellst
möglich die Ursache Ihrer Schmerzen wissen möchten. Aber Herr Piper, als Erster, wir haben immer drei
Schritte, um eine Diagnose stellen zu können. Zuerst einem Nesengespräch, danach körperliche
Untersuchung und schließlich operative Diagnostik. Wir haben ja nur das Analysegespräch beendet.
Wir haben also noch zwei Schritte vor. Nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einer
Trombose. Oh, ist das gefährlich? Trombose in Ihrem Bein. Ja, das muss unbedingt behandelt werden.
Was kann man denn da machen? Ja, aber das ist jetzt nur ein Verdacht. Es muss noch bestätigt werden.
Ja, jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, danach bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen und manche operative
Diagnostik veranlassen und ich werde mit meiner Obererstin sprechen, wie wir weiter folgen.
Okay. Dann werde ich Sie rechtzeitig informieren, was zu tun ist. Ja, okay, das klingt vernünftig.
Ja, gut, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen? Meine Seite hat keine Frage.
Aber ich höre jetzt gerade Herr Günnes, Sie sind erkältet, ne? Ja, Covid.
Ehrlich? Oh nein! Ja, und seit wann?
Alle haben Covid und ich habe keine Covid-Erkältung gehabt und ich hoffe, dass ich eine Covid erkältet.
Und danach ist es momentan. Ja, aber seit wann haben Sie sich getestet?
Heute. Und der war positiv. Herr Günnes, Ihr Test war positiv heute? Ja, test positiv.
Heute, ich habe ein Test durchgeführt und positiv Covid.
Okay, dann passen Sie gut auf sich auf, ne? Das ist ein dummes Ding dieser Infekt.
Und jetzt sind Sie schön isoliert. In der Familie ist noch jemand krank?
Ja, alles Covid. Alle sind krank? Oh nein! Ach Gott, ja.
Und jetzt leben Sie von Konservendosen oder haben Sie irgendjemand, der Sie versorgt?
Nein. Der einkauft für Sie oder so?
Jetzt momentan, keine, keine, haben wir keine Einkaufen gekauft.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Ja, heute und morgen haben wir gemacht, ich weiß nicht, aber heute und morgen kein Problem.
Na ja, gut, okay. Aber Ihre Kinder wohnen noch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Sind Sie denn auch krank? Ja, krank, aber Covid-Test negativ.
Okay. Symptome haben gleich Covid. Ach so? Oh ja, dann kann es natürlich auch mal sein,
dass der Test einfach nicht richtig anschlecht, ne? Oh, ist das doof, ja.
Also, sind Sie denn geimpft? Ja, dreimal geimpft.
Ich habe eine Termin bekommen, vier Termin, aber ich habe eine Termin, vier Termin, Covid.
Ja, die kriegen Sie jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Nicht jetzt, momentan, Covid, ich spiele.
Ich denke, die machen das dann nicht, ne? Wenn man krank war, dann warten die jetzt nochmal sechs Wochen,
oder so, bis man wieder geimpft werden kann. Ja.
Aber dann haben Sie auf alle Fälle diese neue Variante wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ach Mann, wie doof. Also, ja, ich habe eigentlich große Sorge,
weil ich denke, dass überall Leute rumlaufen, die eigentlich positiv sind
und die, die das einfach nicht, nicht checken
und trotzdem einkaufen gehen und das, was ich unter Leute gehen, ne?
Als das gescheblich anfangen, können wir anfangen?
Ja, okay. Ja.
Guten Abend Frau Oberestin. Ich möchte einen neuen Patientin vorstellen, Darfi.
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Frank Pfeiffer ist ein 35-jährige Patient.
Er ist 1,84 Meter groß und 92 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich, er stellte sich wegen Zeit, 2 Tage bestehender,
5-6 Jahre, unter Schenkelschmerzen,
und unter Einnahme von Ibuprofen zeigt es sich keine Besserung.
Die Schmerzen seien andauend und früher habe er noch nie ähnliche Schmerzen gehabt.
Erkelte und bedingte Nachweiss.
An vor Erkrankungen nannte der Patient vor drei Jahren Diagnostizierte Glutenentropatien.
Wie heißt das noch?
Er wurde noch nie operiert.
Er nahm 100 Kilogramm eine Morte und Ibuprofen bei Besar.
Die Gluten allergie sind in der Unverträglichkeit und der Novalgienallergie.
Sieben Stunden dauern wir.
Das ist der Post schon.
Da war der Reise.
Jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit oder wie?
In letzter Zeit.
Er ist nicht.
Aber früher.
Er habe.
6.
1 später casual.
Äh,
äh,
in der Familie Anamnese ergaben sich operierte Kulonkartino Bayen-Pata
und er habe jetzt inspiratet und er hat nie gelenkt die Probleme beider Mutter.
Er habe eine Gesundheit und er lebt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Er treibe kein Sport. Die anamnistische Angaben beuten am ersten auf eine tiefe, wenn ein Trombose hin.
Dafür spricht Rötung, Überwärmung, Schwellung, einseitig Unterchenkelschmerzen
und die Immobilisierung durch 7 Stunden Autofahrt.
Was wäre der Diagnostisch möglich?
Als die Fernsehsdiagnostische kommen Trombopilibitis, Peripherikartärelle,
Persfunkkrankheit und das Alter des Patienten
nicht entspricht für eine Peripherikartärelle Persfunkkrankheit.
Was könnte es denn noch unter Umständen sein?
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten jetzt diagnostisch?
Was machen Sie da besonders?
Diese drei Zeichen, worauf achten Sie dabei?
Wo dürfen Sie noch drücken und das muss weh tun?
Was gibt es die richtige Gewissheit?
Während diese parkourierten Sonographie fehlende oder weniger komprimielle Wahrheit ist ein Nachweis für eine Trombose.
Was machen Sie in der Labortechnik?
Was würden Sie vor allen Dingen bestimmen?
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Bei der Entlastung muss die Therapie mit einer Oralantkoholant vorsetzen werden.
Bei diesem Patienten würde ich gerne drei Monate antikoagulieren.
Was machen Sie noch außer der Antikoagulation?
Was machen Sie noch?
Was machen Sie mit der Erkrankung?
Wie lange soll der Strom tragen?
Was geben Sie in der Dauerhaft für Empfehlung?
Was machen Sie mit der Immobilisierung?
Was würden Sie ihm da empfehlen?
Was könnte er noch machen?
Was machen Sie mit der Immobilisierung?
Wie haben Sie sich gefühlt?
Wären Sie bitte schnell wieder gesund, passen Sie alle gut auf sich auch.
Bis Donnerstag, sage ich mal.